bonsoir il est 18 heures si vous nous
rejoignez en direct pour une nouvelle
édition du 7 suites l'actuel le journal
de la rédaction nous allons faire le
tour de l'actualité de ce 26 février
pour débuter ce journal la mobilisation
cet après midi des adhérents du club de
football de trappes fait rarissime ils
ont manifesté et donc devant la mairie
pour dénoncer un mauvais entretien des
infrastructures se moureu où il n'y
aurait plus d'entraînement depuis un
mois et demi anthony rech
et j'en attends vim le club de football
de trappes et la mairie entame un
nouveau match
trois semaines après la démission du
président mustapha larbaoui entre 150 et
250 enfants éducateurs et parents ont
crié leur colère sous les fenêtres de
l'hôtel de ville on s'entretue parce
qu'elles étaient des intempéries des
terrains sont grands et pour des
testicules t on ne peut pas y aller
c'est la sécurité parce qu'au jour
d'aujourd'hui on bricole et un jeu au
loin des pépins on ouvre on ne
reprochera dans les rangs du club
seulement quatre terrains serait
fonctionnelle de au stade robert bravo
et deux à gilbert gensac dont un réservé
exclusivement à la compétition et tout
cela pour 900 licenciés
de son côté la mairie avance que huit
terrains seraient disponibles sur la
commune dans l'attenté d'une éventuelle
signature de convention avec la ville de
la verrière pour des prêts de terrain le
club trappistes semble se retrouver dans
l'impasse on considère que ce sera
d'être à peu que vous pratiquez le
football de manière correcte
donc aujourd'hui on a des revendications
très très simple qui consiste à demander
des lieux accueillants pour les
adhérents et lieu sécurisé en cause
adversaires
nikon et des outils pour travailler
malgré leur demande d'audience la
délégation n'a pas été reçu par le maire
guy malandain ou ses représentants
à noter que la direction d'un autre club
de football du département vient aussi
d'annoncer sa démission c'est à
versailles les douze membres du fcv 78
ont décidé de claquer la porte il pointe
du doigt eux aussi le manque de soutien
de la municipalité alors que bien
évidemment vous le savez les élections
approchent dans trois mois presque jour
pour jour se déroulent les élections
européennes cette fois ci c'est l'autre
grand rendez vous électoral de cette
année elle se joue en un seul tour puis
c'est uniquement le dimanche 25 mai que
seront désignés les 74 députés français
européen et qui siègeront à côté de
leurs 677 homologues des autres pays
quelles sont les différentes
institutions qui composent l'europe
entre le parlement qui est installée à
strasbourg la commission européenne dans
laquelle siègent 28 commissaire européen
ou encore le conseil de l'europe lui
aussi implanté à bruxelles est difficile
parfois de s y retrouver et pourtant ces
élections sont capitales 4x de la tossée
en duo avec patrick jacques de dixmude à
bruxelles pour en savoir plus on va
essayer de comprendre évidemment un peu
mieux les le fonctionnement de l'europe
avec vous et marc taquet quinzaine
bonjour on retrouve donc ici à la
commission européenne et puis derrière
nous on a les photos des fameux
commissaire européen gamma 28 commission
présidée par josé manuel barroso parmi
les commissaires on à un français michel
barnier
d'abord la commission européenne elle
sert à quoi alors le le principal rôle
de la commission européenne c'est de
représenter l'intérêt général non de
considérer la situation sur un thème
donné dans tous les états membres et
ensuite et bien identifier à quel est
l'intérêt commun et de faire des
propositions qui vont servir de base de
discussion
donc c'est la commission qui fait des
propositions oui on peut même aller plus
loin on peut même dire que la commission
a le monopole de l'initiative c'est à
dire que son rôle sa nature c'est
vraiment de faire des propositions qui
seront ensuite adopté par le parlement
européen et par les états membres
comprennent bien donc commission
européenne à l'initiative
vous l'avez dit des propositions il ya
effectivement ce parlement européen
c'est peut-être ce qui est plus le plus
connu pour les citoyens parce que c'est
là où siègent les députés
ouais et comment dire si l'une des
institutions donc dont les pouvoirs se
sont considérablement étendu
or des dernières réformes
institutionnelles il faut pas oublier
quand même le conseil c'est à dire les
états membres on sait que comment dire
cessé de l'institution qui légifèrent
avec le parlement européen sur les
propositions de la commission
il ya deux autres institutions qui sont
la cour de justice et la cour européenne
des comptes
oui la cour des comptes européenne et la
cour de justice comme vous voulez les
manches et la cour de justice en
particulier à jouer un rôle important
dans le cadre juridique de l'union
européenne c'est une communauté de droit
et joue un rôle important aussi dans
l'interprétation du droit communautaire
je voudrais revenir sur cette commission
européenne qui désigne les commissaires
ne sont pas ils sont pas élus par le
peuple au point la différence des
députés européens
c'est juste et en même temps quelque
part il est là il le saut c'est à dire
d'abord les le président de la
commission européenne est proposée par
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement
n'ont vraiment plus haut niveau de
l'union européenne et ensuite chaque
état membre proposera un candidat
commissaire le parlement européen
intervient dans la mesure où il va
procéder une double investiture du
collège de commissaires donc il va
d'abord investir le président de la
commission et ensuite il va investir le
collège dans son ensemble après requis
pour retoquer un commissaire qui lui
plairait pas tout à fait c'est déjà
arrivé de le dire et de le faire c'est à
dire il ya demanda le parlement européen
avait rejeté le candidat italien rocco
buttiglione pour
commentaires homophobes durant
l'audition parlement européen parce que
chaque commissaire avant que le
parlement européen investissent le
collège bien et auditionné par par des
commissions parlementaires et lors de la
dernière investiture c'est la
commissaire bulgare candidate
commissaire bulgare qui avait été rejeté
par le parlement européen
lorsqu'un portons aussi dire c'est que
le commission européen même si les
français marion si vous tombez à michel
barnier
même si les français portent pas la voix
de la france il doit porter de la voix
de l'europe
ça c'est pas des fois bien il ya claire
ou bien compréhensible mais c'est
pourtant une réalité tout à fait c'est
non seulement une réalité mais c'est
improbable principe fondamental c'est à
dire que chaque commissaire est là pour
représenter l'intérêt européen défendre
l'intérêt général n'est pas là pour
défendre les intérêts particuliers ou
les aperçus en gros qui défend les
intérêts de son pays c'est celui dans le
chef de gouvernement le chef d'état qui
siège au sein du conseil de l'europe
tout à fait c'est à dire c'est au
conseil que sont défendus représenter
les intérêts
les intérêts nationaux et ça veut dire
que la commission européenne du coup on
a une vision me dit j'ai d'avoir une
vision lointaine on a un regard
visionnaire puisque ben visionnaire dans
la mesure où souvent on regardera les
c'est bon les tendances à long terme en
europe
visionnaire aussi dans ce sens où ça
vous offre une perspective européenne
-hors sur beaucoup de thèmes de société
aujourd'hui vous ne pouvez pas faire une
analyse efficace
vous ne pouvez pas agir sur la réalité
sans adopter une dimension européenne
sur la question de réforme du secteur
financier de politique énergétique de
politique environnementale
bien à vous trouver des solutions vous
devez trouver des solutions au niveau du
continent peut agir évidemment au niveau
national mais surtout c'est m on ne peut
avoir prise sur la réalité que l'échelle
du continent
je reviens sur cette commission
européenne aujourd'hui le composé de 28
membres c'est compliqué regardez c'est
comme si compliquée qu'au début et voilà
c'est compliqué c'est beaucoup c'est à
dire que le fonctionnement collégial de
l'institution voudrait qu'il y ait un
nombre plus limité de commissaire c'est
à dire que là que le fonctionnement
collégial de l'institution barle assure
la qualité des décisions dans la mesure
où chaque commissaire doit consulter ses
homologues
quel que soit quelques soli initiative
et
comment dire l'institution fonctionne
d'autant mieux en collège que vous avez
un groupe de membres
r c'était j'aime de laurent qui lisait
connaught 17 17 membres décident
commissaire européen ça devenait
difficile de prendre des décisions et là
il y en avait un tweet on qu'on se doute
que c'est bien que c'est bien compliqué
tout à fait le 25 mai donc ce sont les
élections européennes
elles sont à son tour elles sont un seul
tour oui c'est important il ya un
modifications
cette possible pour ces élections c'est
à dire que du coup il y aurait une
représentativité politique plus
importante
alors ce cas la voix du peuple va être
portée différents oui la devise la
devise d'ailleurs du parlement européen
pour ces élections
c'est cette fois ci c'est différent
alors qu'est ce qui change pour ces
élections si c'est que un protocole du
traité de lisbonne prévoit que lorsque
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement vont
nommer d'abord le candidat président de
la commission et ensuite les candidats
commissaires
il doit prendre en compte le résultat
des élections alors ce n'était pas le
cas de manière aussi explicite
auparavant ce qui veut dire pour le
parlement européen très concrètement que
logiquement les chefs d'état
gouvernement vont devoir nommer le
candidat officiel du groupe politique
qui aura gagné les élections au
parlement européen à la présidence de la
commission donc le parlement interprète
ce protocole de lisbonne manière très
précise
aujourd'hui pour cette prochaine
élection et bien chaque groupe politique
va proposer des candidats va proposer
des programmes et le vainqueur des
élections c'est-à-dire le groupe
politique ou programme qui organise les
élections et bien aura la possibilité de
voir son se voir nommé président de la
commission et aura pour tâche de mettre
en oeuvre un programme qui pour le coup
ce sera un programme politique qui
aurait été proposé pendant la campagne
avant la campagne électorale et on sait
que les élections européennes en général
mobilise pas beaucoup est-ce que par par
cette façon de faire est ce que ça peu
plus mobiliser les citoyens qui du coup
son voile attendre les tendances
nationales seront mieux représentés à la
commission européenne
alors oui on peut espérer que le fait
que ces élections aient lieu selon des
modalités sensiblement différente
devrait créer plus d'intérêt de fait
aujourd'hui plusieurs mois avant les
élections européennes
il ya déjà beaucoup de débats sur
justement les candidats qui sont
proposées par les groupes politiques
ça permet de personnaliser aussi les
élections c'est à dire de mettre un
visage sur chacun des programmes qui
sera proposé donc idéalement cela
devrait favoriser un intérêt majeur pour
les élections européennes parce que ça
rend plus clair le fait que chaque
citoyen là se prononcent sur un candidat
sur un programme et donc fait un choix
réel
là on verra ça à l'issue du 25 mai merci
beaucoup marqué la scène il va répondre
à nos questions merci un tout autre
sujet à présent dans ce journal après ce
plateau réalisé depuis bruxelles le
festival du cirque et qui vient de vivre
sa 13e édition aux mureaux 46 artistes
de renommée internationale pour des
numéros revisiter les grands classiques
rencontre sous le chapiteau avec aurélia
de bissy et anthony rech pour les images
le temps d'un week end sous le chapiteau
installé parc du sceau tour
une quarantaine d'artistes ont paradé
dans l'arène entre disciplines
traditionnelles
moderne le festival du cirque des murs
ont créé en 2001 sous l'impulsion de la
commune est devenu l'un des plus
renommés en ile de france un mouvement
populaire et familial qui pour cette 13e
édition maintient une politique
tarifaire attractive avec des places
comprise entre 5 12 euros des artistes
venus du monde entier ont fait valoir
leur talent sous la houlette de monsieur
loyal cette année encore en charge de la
programmation d'apporter un vrai un beau
spectacle de cirque à la portée de
toutes les bourses c'est à dire que les
familles les plus les moins riches qui
peuvent pas se payer des places à 45
euros soit 50 euros voire 60 parfois
puissent voir le même spectacle un tarif
à la portée de tous parce que le rêve à
partir du monde et c'est aussi le circle
le seul endroit le sel c'est le seul que
j'avais le seul cercle d'amour parce que
c'est le seul endroit où il y avait une
véritable intégration et acceptation de
toutes nationalités toutes toute
religion toute mentalité
quelle qu'elle soit pour la première
fois aux mureaux la troupe eagles des
artistes gabonais nous présenter leurs
spécialités
la chromatique recommencer avec la
centrale
de fierté de fabrice alloi qu' on peut
s'intéresser à la culture de la monnaie
le cirque tout cet africain tout est
exécuté avec la danse africaine de la
danse africaine ouverte à n'importe quel
la numéro revisités aux grands
classiques
le cirque a pour essence de créer des
émotions chez le spectateur ou prouesse
technique qui l'exploit au toit création
artistique il chorégraphie et n'oubliez
pas le rendez vous culture de la
rédaction chaque mercredi 18h30 kiosque
avec aurélia de bissy ce 26 février elle
reviendra sur cette opération de
sensibilisation la musique pour les
candidats aux municipales vote ont plus
de musique c'est le nom de cette
initiative
on reste dans le monde de la culture
plus particulièrement dans celui des
super héros un univers qui rencontre un
énorme succès pendant les vacances à
magny les hameaux ce sont les enfants
qui ont fabriqué comme leur idole leur
idole leurs costumes car avant de partir
sauver un le monde il faut aussi savoir
maîtriser les fondamentaux de la couture
regardez ce reportage de romain g est
qui n'a pas rêvé d'avoir des pouvoirs
extraordinaires pendant une semaine les
stimuler à magny les hameaux invité les
enfants à façonner leur costume de super
héros
selon leur imagination ils ont dessiné
les différents éléments du déguisement
on m'avait demandé du coup de venir
faire une semaine de création de
costumes de super-héros en essayant de
changer un petit peu les codes des super
héros pas forcément venir faire le
costume de batman de spider man ou voilà
mais plutôt de s'approprier le super
héros à soi les enfants ont appris les
bases de la couture
ils sont prêts à rééditer cette
expérience chez eux bien soi-même on se
fait après maintenant matin je pourrais
le refaire et c'est bien de le refaire
comme ça on pourra le donner à quelqu'un
d'autre
l approche de mardi gras les enfants
pourront jouer les apprentis justicier
avec leurs propres costumes l'acte qui
revient demain 18h en direct avec à la
présentation anthony rech je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée sur notre
antenne